l'hiver approche c'est l'époque de la
transhumance et pourquoi l'on croit sans
arrêt de nombreuses caravanes de nomades
leur route durera plusieurs semaines car
ils se rendent jusque indus dans le nord
ouest de l'inde
les femmes sont dévoilés et vous allez
le voir les enfants sont bercés plus ou
moins mollement les porsche amoureux
sont chargés jusqu'aux dents il
transporte toutes les batteries de
cuisine les temps une bidon d'essence
vide et les chaises les matelas les
animaux familiers les chalets poule
enfin tout est né de cette année les
petits chameau suivent derrière
avant l'an prochain pas de corvée pour
lui n'a pas voulu se séparer de son
tapis que c'était peut être sa plus
belle richesse
puis c'est l'heure de la halte heures
toujours décidés par le chef veneman
quelques retardataires qui de toute
façon trouveront une place
le départ se fera demain à 3 heures du
matin en attendant chacun vaque au
chemin du camp i et à son confort
personnel
allumez le feu préparer le repas
s'abriter pour la nuit et se reposer et
faire reposer aussi les chameaux
où
tombé en panne sur une piste peut être
angoissant mais à la période de
transhumance tout finit par s'arranger
et vous allez le voir on a quelquefois
besoins mondiaux la suite vous la
connaissez
wall et pittoresque
il
et puis près de lahore au pakistan ce
paradis terrestre
les jardins de shalimar en 16 137 sharan
s'est pris d'une jeune fille est pour
elle il construisit ce fastueux jardin
c'est parce que maintenant sont
transformés en jardin public chacun peut
venir y méditer y rêver s'y reposer ou
admirer
dans l' or ou gris la foule s'est déjà
l'inde
vous le savez le pakistan et l'inde
musulmane devenue indépendante en 1947
c'est une ville où triomphent les petits
métiers vendeurs de sucreries de
bracelets de bimbeloterie un léger
accident qui n'a guère impressionné ou
notre fumeur de pipe à eau pour quelques
anna monnaie du lieu vous pourrez être
véhiculé de la sorte au pied de la
grande mosquée des hommes grotte des
étoffes précieuses et les manèges de la
ba qui est nouveau la roue à eau
on s'amuse bien quand même vous savez
non non ce n'est pas la sortie d'un
match de football mais j'ai une rude
amristar au nord de leurs abris star la
capitale religieuse des sites
là se trouve vous allez voir le temple
d'or incrusté de diamants
le voici à ses pieds les pèlerins
viennent se purifier
les sikhs forme d'une fraternité
religieuse 5 règles ils sont
fondamentales porter la barbe les
cheveux longs portait un caleçon pour
avoir toujours un bracelet d'acier au
bras gauche être munis d'un peigne et
d'un poignard l'eau sacrée les attend
ils rêvent tous de s'y plonger
et pour ce faire il accomplit des
milliers de kilomètres
geste de coquetterie non gestes utiles
refaire son chignon que l'on cachera
sous le turbo
une élégante de hautes castes et son
époux à une régie pour tenir sa barbe
voilà on met le turban sur le chic fille
est exquise et fines elles attendent que
leurs parents aient achevé leurs
ablutions
aujourd'hui dans la région une fête est
donnée en l'honneur de manas il est le
fondateur de la secte
né en 14 969 son culte est basée sur
l'amour du prochain
c'est à cheval que les prêtres 6e rang
au lieu du rassemblement
les couleurs sacré de la religion sont
le bleu et le jaune tous les moyens de
locomotion sont bons pour ceux qui
veulent venir cette réunion l'éléphant
le cheval et la bicyclette
enfin tout ce qu'ils avancent
on se croirait à hollande
non c'est pas le marché aux puces indien
mais les chaussures ses chaussures ont
été abandonné momentanément par leurs
propriétaires et groupées par trois ou
quatre perd 5000 personnes et plus sont
venus honorer la mémoire de nanak le
prophète
car aujourd'hui la communauté offre un
repas et pour ces gens pauvres et
sous-alimenté c'est un véritable festin
il n'est composé que de chats pâtissent
galettes de blés et d'une louche ou de
haricots au kerry le tout posé sur une
feuille
quant aux t il est servi dans un
récipient en terre que l'on brise après
usage
la politesse exige que l'on se serve en
guise d'argenterie des trois doigts de
la main droite
cette fête a lieu une fois l'an et
demain chacun reviendra au régime
quotidien une tasse de thé une galette
est un peu de vie
à agra le taj mahal ouais j'en passe
comme vous l'a déjà fait visiter
souvenez vous en nous le devons à
l'empereur moghol jorane qui le fit
édifier pour sa femme décédée pieuse
pensée qui laisse à la postérité une
oeuvre d'art peut à bosse charette
auroux étrange toute l'inde
il y as 400 millions d'habitants en un
mais il est certain qu'il ya autant de
bovidés pas de travail pour les vaches
puisque m elles sont sacrées le boeuf
les rangs en place son lieu de
prédilection la mare une fille votre
dans la vase de préférence aussi son
propriétaire est il obligé de passer son
temps à le nettoyer
fin novembre la mouche on est terminée
c'est la saison russe douce comme notre
président les aigrettes blanche
s'éveille
il existe encore là-bas des nomades
diseurs de bonne aventure des
troubadours balade d'un charmeur de
serpents et montreur d'ours
e
et au son des fifres quelle race
lutte continuelle entre la vie et la
mort étrangement solidaire les vautours
ignoble et cependant combien utile ils
assurent le service de voirie et sens
aux yeux le pire épidémie serait
papillon
planes c'est aussi le pays des vaches
elles y sont sacrés elles sont partout
grâce indolente hargneux elle encombrent
les trottoirs et broutent à toutes les
demandes
bénarès le spectacle est dans l'art
marchand de fruits de bethel de brocart
de l'âme et de sarry d'ailleurs si qui
travaillent dans pleine rue et la foule
venue de partout à seule fin de se
baigner dans le gange sacré
sur série se sont entraînés ce qui sont
venus ici pour y mourir
et croyez moi ils le feront misty les
pèlerins lavent leurs corps
reims leur linge de leurs vêtements et
ensuite boivent à l'ong gorges et ses
taux dans laquelle flotte vaches mort
aux rats serpents des briques cadavres
sans doute chantent-ils immunisés mais
pour vraiment voir bénarès il faut être
sur le gange à bord d'une barque palais
ancienne demeure de maharajah du temple
et le temps à autre une frêle fumée
bleue monte vers le ciel
c'est la fumée des morts que nuitées
joue on incinère et qui rappellent où
vivent la précarité de leur existence
terrestre
yoann paillot vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de jacques corner et de
solange péters montage pierre michel rey
son ami cuvellier script lucette andreï
illustration sonore dominic palladini